today we feature Philip Goff a leading
professor and philosopher of the Mind
Durham University he's also a
best-selling author and a good friend
you've seen him on Joe Rogan and on Lex
frieman and his work revolves around the
intricacies of Consciousness exploring
profound questions that challenge our
understanding of reality critical of
materialism and dualism he Advocates a
new kind of psychism the view that
Consciousness is a fundamental and
ubiquitous feature of the physical world
I found it fascinating even if I don't
always agree as you'll see in his most
recent book aptly titled why the purpose
of the universe he explores the meaning
and purpose and challenges to the
Western thought dominated by the
dichotomy of traditional religion and
secular atheism join us on a
thought-provoking sometimes provocative
and confrontational journey into the
mind the nature of existence and the
ultimate purpose of the universe welcome
everybody to a meaningful and
purpose-filled edition of the into the
impossible podcast featuring a second
time returning guest the incomparable
Professor Philip Goff joining us all the
way from the UK how are you today Phil
I'm very well good to see you again
Brian I'm looking forward to chatting
yes some people were surprised that I
had you back on because you wrote this
book and it sort of suggests that my
hero Galileo made some mistak so we
already talked about that in your
previous wonderful book Galileo's error
sitting behind you on your shelf but
today we're going to talk about really
some
incredibly uh incredibly uh audacious
goals such as meaning existence religion
and the ultimate purpose of the universe
and I'm a cosmologist and you're a
philosopher and uh I think between the
two of us we can get it solved in the
next hour so what I love to do is always
have an author walk through the process
of the cover books judgment so you're
not supposed to you know have a
categorical imperative but I I do want
to understand what was the origin the
Genesis the purpose of the title The
subtitle and the Beautiful color
illustration I should say this is by
Oxford press and it's incredibly well
it's just a beautiful book uh so they
did a great job as usual Phil judge this
book by its
cover it is a great cover isn't it yeah
there there is a bit of a story actually
so I think the um the My editor had the
idea initially of Aztec Ruins I think he
thought like he didn't want it to be too
cliched if you thinking of the purpose
of the universe you know you might have
stars or a face in the star so you
wanted it to be really different to that
and then my wife found this wonderful
series of photographs online of of
nature overpowering old buildings and
it's sort of the sense of this broader
purpose than human purpose kind of
encompassing everything and then I chose
that one in particular and then the
design team with the publisher did did
this incredible job so yeah yeah that's
wonderful in terms of the title
originally I was calling it the ex the
purpose of the universe or the purpose
of existence and then maybe that sounds
a bit academically a few people
including my grandmother-in-law now I
through my wife I have grandparents
in-law and she was one of the people who
suggested why not just call it why and
so we thinking for them for you know
maybe just why would be wonderfully
enigmatic and intriguing but I think
together with the subtitle which sums it
up it really
encapsulates it it's really as I say
it's audacious it's it's wonderful and
we have a lot of uh lot of questions and
comments uh from my audience who I
pinged earlier this morning um but I
guess the the you know the big question
that I still have trouble reconciling
and I've talked to one of the men who
gave you and my audience hates when I
name drop so I'm going to name drop in
uh in you know just just throughout the
conversation but uh Donald Hoffman one
of my most popular guests in addition to
your appearances and Don says you know
he calls this book lucid and riveting
with rare audacity goof blazes new
trails it's fascinating terrain to
explore go provides proves an expert and
genial guide and I have to agree having
read it but but Phil the problem I still
have is I've talked to you and Don and
uh David chers and many many other
people and I still don't understand what
pan psychism is and that's still a Hot
Topic uh in in what we cover and I had a
lot of questions for my audience on
YouTube and you can always ask me
questions and you should follow Phil on
Twitter on YouTube he a thriving YouTube
channel we have a link to it but Phil
people don't get pan psychism you're one
of its foremost cheerleaders it makes an
appearance here tell us can you give us
a definition and maybe it'll get through
my thick skull what is pans psychism and
why is it relevant to the purpose of the
universe if if at all psychism is the
view that Consciousness goes right down
to the fundamental building blocks of
reality so maybe I mean it's a question
for physics right what the the
fundamental building blocks of reality
are maybe the particles maybe the
universe wide Fields but whatever they
are the idea is that they have
incredibly simple
rudimentary forms of experience so
nothing like the kind of experience a
human being has after millions of years
of evolution but Consciousness comes in
all shapes and sizes so the you know
what it's like to be a human being is
very rich and complex what it's like to
be a sheep significantly simpler what
it's like to be a snail simpler still
and as we move to simpler and simpler
forms of life we find simpler and
simpler forms of subjective experience
for the pans psychist that keeps going
right down to the fundamental building
blocks of reality that have incredibly
simple forms of experience at least if
they're particles I guess if they
Universe wide Fields they might have
incredibly complex forms of experience
but still
conceptually very simple it's not like
they're sort of contemplating their own
existence or something in the form of
you know kind of this word experience
and I'm not making a comparison but I
had deac Chopra on you know my podcast
several years ago he is a friend and he
lives in San Diego so we we get to hang
out on occasion you know he also spoke
in in certain terms about experience and
and um and and sort of nebulous terms to
a physics audience and remember you're
talking to the world's most brilliant
podcast audience and they can go deep
into you know Advanced relativity
quantum mechanics Etc by what way let's
just focus on electrons I think they're
probably the most simple thing we could
talk about I don't think we can really
contemplate you know uh in detail you
know the the top Quark or something like
that and how it might exp let's just
focus on electrons how does an electron
experience anything and and what if
anything would it experience uh and so
what does experience mean in the in the
context of a quantum mechanical particle
who can which can be descri I don't say
who now I'm lapsing into true
anthropomorphism and so forth what does
it mean to experience something I mean
it's important to be clear what we're
meaning by Consciousness we're not
meaning self-consciousness awareness of
your own existence uh that's something
rabbits probably don't have never mind
electrons we're just meaning any kind of
subjective
experience Thomas Nagel famously
captured it by saying something is
conscious if there's something that it's
like to be it and as I say you know we
can get we can imagine simpler and
simpler forms of Consciousness to bed
bugs have experienc it's going to be
almost incredibly simple and there
doesn't seem to be any conceptual limit
to how simple experience could be and in
that way there doesn't seem to be any
incoherence in something incredibly
rudimentary without any conceptual
understanding of the world around it
just having some very kind of simple
experience correspond responding to its
incredibly simple um physical structure
now of course it just because it's
coherent doesn't mean it's true we've
got to look to the you know the reasons
to take this view seriously but maybe in
the way shape is a very is a very
flexible concept you know it's like all
sorts of conceivable different
geometries maybe if you'd lived in a
world where you'd only accounted very
complicated geometry very complicated
shapes the idea of a very very simple
triangle or something might be how could
shape be so simple but of course it is a
very flexible concept likewise with
subjective experience we're used to
thinking of experience in terms of human
beings these very highly evolved
creatures or complex animals but I think
psychism is in a way very cernic the uh
I've done a few public discussions with
the with the writer Philip pman who
draws inspiration from pism and
he put this to me that it's very cernic
so we're not thinking of conscious
modeled on the very from in a pansus
perspective the very weird kind of
Consciousness that a human being has
because it's so highly evolved and
molded by those forces of evolution but
it's very very flexible notion very very
different to the human case but still
being just some kind of inner life or
experience I thought you were going to
pull out uh when you mentioned Thomas
Nagel you know what is it like to be a
bat and my follow-up book is what is it
like to be Thomas Nagel by a bat or bat
U but the conclusion of that you know
monograph is basically we can't know and
and that's with a mammal right so all
the more so with with a particle and I
guess I I guess how how entwined is the
notion of panm with your current book
obviously that was a big thrust I mean
how do you view it in terms of purpose I
mean obviously something cannot have a
purpose or you know teolog as you
philosophers might say um if it's not
conscious or if it if it or it could
participate in the theological purpose
but how does it how does it instantiate
it I guess that's what I'm looking for
we're in the wave equation or in you
know Einstein's field equation where you
know where do we need Consciousness and
then if you can say that we don't need
it you know to kind of paraphrase Sean
Carol who makes appearances throughout
your work uh how does it how does it
matter if it doesn't interact with the
standard model more or less and I don't
agree with Sean on most things by the
way but but here I I think there's some
notion of applicability if it doesn't if
we can't put it into Hilbert space or we
can't put it into a wave equation does
it matter good so let me say a little
bit about the case for pan psychism and
then maybe connected to Cosmic purpose
which is the focus of this book and yeah
well sea and I recently did a public
debate in um in the states which people
can get on YouTube maybe we can link to
it uh which was a lot of fun a very
spirited but good-spirited debate it was
there was some gasps from the audience
at some of the strong comments but it
was all in good good fun yeah so what we
have at the core of the issues with
Consciousness is I mean I don't think
this is a purely scientific problem when
it comes to Consciousness I think we
have here at root as well as the the
scientific issues of Consciousness which
are hugely important an ancient problem
that philosophers have traditionally
referred to as the mindbody problem
which is the difficulty of how we fit
together the physical world and
Consciousness how they fit together we
know they both exist we know about
Consciousness just because we're
conscious and we're immediately aware of
our feelings and experiences we know
about the physical world in a very
different way through our senses through
doing science so we've got these two
portals on reality two things we know
about in quite different ways how do
they fit together and there are a few
different options you know may maybe
it's the physical world that's
fundamental and Consciousness arises
from physical process is in the brain
that's the physicalist approach someone
like sha would adopt and many others but
the psychist says well it could be the
other way around it could be that
Consciousness is fundamental and
physical reality arises from more
fundamental facts about mind or
Consciousness there's a third option the
DU list option that they're both
fundamental but radically different and
crucially right why is this not a
scientific question because you can't
you can't find out which of these views
is right with an experiment for any
experimental data each Theory will just
interpret it on their own terms so so
how can we decide people I mean people
find that annoying it's like okay well
what what can we do if we can't do an
experiment but what we can do is try and
look at the explanatory aspirations of
these two viewpoints and which does
better so what's the explanatory
aspiration of the physicalist they try
to explain the emergence of
Consciousness in terms of physical brain
processes how well as has that gone I
would argue after Decades of our
greatest Minds putting serious effort
into this I would argue it's gone
absolutely nowhere we've never managed
to explain a single experience in terms
of underlying neural activity and also I
think pretty good philosophical
arguments that it's just not really a
coherent project whereas when it comes
to pans psychism it's explanatory
aspiration is the other way around try
to explain the emergence of physical
reality from underlying fact about
Consciousness and I would argue there
the Mysteries are already solved we've
already worked out how to do that and
this is the
inspiration of certain really important
work berch and Russell did in the
1920s thinking about Consciousness and
how physical reality might be
constructed from underlying facts about
Consciousness well maybe we could go
into this and in particular his book The
analysis of matter in 1927 I think we
should think of Russell as the Darwin of
Consciousness I think he really solved
all the Mysteries here okay so we've got
you know physicalism never got anywhere
of jubia coherence I would argue pans
sism feels weird doesn't fit with our
current culture but it it delivers the
goods we we know how to make sense of it
we know it works so that's why I think
it's the more plausible view I could go
into Cosmic purpose but I've talked a
bit too long already did you want to
raise anything there or should I go I I
often lapse into uh you know longer
monologues as the host and I'm shooting
you know my my uh listeners tell me I
should shoot for a a 30 to 70 ratio of
uh of speaking to uh to to listening but
uh but I do want to hear about that
because I think a core thesis of the
book is is that you kind of give you
upgrade you know traditional religious
views and secular views as as both of
them kind of being wholly inadequate for
the situation of determining meaning now
I'm a practicing Jew and and uh you know
I go to a temple you know I can
get around a prayer book uh I'm very
well versed in in Jewish philosophy Etc
and it's one of the oldest religions on
earth right it's the it's a precursor to
you know three or four billion people's
Faith choices so I think it's pretty
shocking right that people will say wait
a second this is inadequate so make your
case with we're going to turn to
cosmology believe me because that's how
my bread is buttered around the kading
household but but tell me Phil why do
you say that traditional religions I
agree atheist is inadequate I I think I
think we we might agree very much have
very much to agree about there why is
traditional religion are 3.8 billion
people wrong that's really fascinating
because yeah I've done a hell of a lot
of interviews on this in the last few
weeks and almost all of them have said
oh yeah of course God doesn't exist but
atheism what's wrong with that and um
but you know it's funny it's like so
that's really refreshing it's really
refreshing that you pushing back from
the other side I mean yeah I always hate
the dichotomies in my work you know you
know it's particularly with this one so
many people feel they have to fit into
this binary you know do you believe in
the god of traditional religion or are
you a secular atheist as I've said a
number of times that you know it's like
which team are you on Richard Dawkins or
or the pope or the chief Rabbi or you
know um youve got to pick your team and
I feel when you're talking to people
they're trying to put you into one of
those categories but I've just slowly
over a long period of time just come to
think that they're both inadequate and
we just I suppose what I'm meaning by
atheism to be clear is the idea of a
meaningless purposeless Universe one of
the deep challenges there I think is the
emergence of the fine-tuning in physics
for life which does think does suggest
on the face of it some kind of purpose
or goal directedness in reality so
that's that's the that's the bit I focus
on there as well as certain facts to do
with the evolution of Consciousness but
coming to your question what's wrong
with the traditional god well here it's
the familiar The Familiar issue for me
of
reconciling and all knowing all powerful
God uh all loving God with the horrific
suffering we find in the world in in the
human world but also what's perhaps less
focused on in in much theodicy the the
natural world you know why would a a a
loving God who could do anything choose
toate cre us through just a long-winded
horrific process like natural selection
why would a loving God create the North
American longtailed shrew that paralyzes
its prey and then eats it alive over
several days before it eventually dies
from its wounds this just kind of makes
no sense to me why why a loving God
would do that so so it's a familiar
problem that I I hope I give some new
takes on and well I might just like to
say briefly before you come back on this
that so my first this book was a was an
academic book over here that you might
be a little impenetrable if you don't
have a PhD in philosophy my next book
was aimed at General audience this
book's trying to do both so each book
each chapter has a more accessible bit
and then a digging deeper bit where I
try to get more into The Cutting Edge of
the field or the technical details or
consider all the objections but yeah so
that's so what so it's the old problem
of evil I guess I I've I've always found
that one of the most compelling
philosophical arguments what do you
think Brian hi there so sorry to
interrupt this meaningful and
purpose-filled episode but I have to get
something important to share to you
right now learning is a lifelong process
so obviously you need all the materials
to learn from somewhere and that's why
you really need to join my mailing list
at banking.com list by joining you also
get the freshest science news from the
farthest reaches of the known universe
delivered straight to your inbox and
you'll automatically be entered to win a
piece of an authentic chunk of space
schuts a meteorite a real fragment of
the early solar system all you got to do
is adjin join my mailing list at
banking.com list and you'll be entered
to join immediately now back to the
episode oh I I agree and of course you
know there are all these tropes Phil
that we could go into you know the the
classic one is that uh you know the the
believer has but one question you know
why do uh bad things happen to good
people uh or why do good things happen
to bad people let me just ask you yeser
or no are are which do you think is more
um is is more painful for you when a
good thing happens to your enemy or when
something bad happens to a friend which
which is worse well it ought to be the
latter and I hope it's the latter I
suppose that's that that's what we we
aspire to I suppose I'm quite lucky that
I've never had
somebody wrong me very very deeply and
maybe I would incline more to the form
in those circumstances I don't know I
hope not there are these wonderful
stories aren't there of um of of people
who manage to forgive in incredible
circumstances and you know that's that's
the aspiration but um is it the name of
the the book you gave then what who who
was the uh was it the a Jewish
philosopher or Theologian who had this
idea of a a deity of limited abilities
or I actually don't call myself a
classic you know theist in the sense of
I call myself a practicing Jew earlier
and what that means is I I think
scientifically a very moderate way to be
is to be what I call a practicing
agnostic and this goes back to my first
ever conversation on this podcast with
your fellow Countryman and I'm sure a
great inspiration to you the late great
Freeman Dyson and so Freeman was my
first guest on this podcast and I asked
them in that conversation and in many
conversations uh subsequent to that you
know what what he meant when he said he
was agnostic and and he would say you
know well I think God is a mystery and
physics is a mystery and I love solving
puzzles and Myster I said that's great
but what do you do what if uh an alien
version of Richard Dawkins was observing
you on a on a Sunday he would see you
and Richard Dawkins doing the same thing
you know maybe watching I don't know
what you guys do cricket match or or
attending in a Royal opera or doing
whatever over there in the in the
beautiful uh UK in other words there's
no functional distinguishing
characteristics of his flavor of of
agnosticism from Dawkins his flavor of
atheism so for me as I said I I eat
kosher food I don't um you know work on
the Sabbath which for me is a Saturday I
um can attend a temple I can read Hebrew
I I I read the portion of the of the
Torah every week that's associated with
that week's reading in the temple uh I
can you know muddle my way through it I
was just in Israel I did my bar mitzvah
at age 52 I never had it as a kid uh for
reasons I'll don't get into so for all
these reasons I said you know Freeman I
love you but um but there's no
difference I mean you're functionally
the same as Richard Dawkins or Lawrence
Krauss who I spoke to recently uh on
stage here in San Diego so I guess my
feeling is theoy is is one of the oldest
challenges I didn't finish the the Trope
the Trope is you know a Believer has but
one question you know how do you explain
the existence of evil in a world created
by God good God you know a good God
right so that is a question it's your
number one question but then they say an
atheist has an infinite number of
questions and I think you know some of
them are addressed in this book The
simulation hypothesis the Multiverse
fine-tuning anthropic principle and
we're going to get into as many of those
as we can but um I guess the the the
question of theodicy has been answered
for 1100 years in Judaism at least to
the extent of interactions between
people like I don't think the Shrew is
evil like I don't whatever that shrew is
and and I have to make a reminder not to
get that for my daughter for for
Hanukkah she always wants these exotic
pets right she wanted actually a kodo
drag
recently but uh that's not going to
happen so Phil uh I don't consider that
evil I consider it you know it's it's
part of nature what I do consider evil
you know terrorism you know torturing
human beings and man-on-man you know
type of violence uh crimes against you
know uh uh things that don't have
purpose like cancer or earthquakes or a
Pandemic those I don't view as evil I I
view those as as awful but they're not
directed and so in my manes ROM and and
judism in the foremost medieval Scholars
you know he answered it in the classic
tense that was later picked up by the
Catholics and Christians and and that is
that you know God had to have to allow
free will there had to be evil committed
by man against man now you may not
believe in Free Will the way I I do I
want to ask you just in a short answer
form do you believe we have free will I
mean is that possible to answer I know
that many people you know Sabina
hossenfelder and and dun Hoffman many
others don't right so do you can you
just say very briefly because we have so
much to cover in the remaining time do
you believe in Free Will or no I know
it's a impossible thing I'm somewhat
agnostic I I don't think the reality of
Free Will is as certain as the reality
of Consciousness it it could turn out to
be an illusion and it's partly an
empirical question however I am very and
I go into this in the book I am very
unconvinced by either the philosophical
or the scientific arguments against Free
Will I think people deny people like um
know who I've been rowing with on
Twitter this week bit in a nice way
maybe you're classy guy it's more of a
Zeitgeist it's just people feels that's
how science ought to be but you know we
don't we know the more I've talked to
neuroscientists The more I've found out
that how little we know about the brain
you know I think I think we know a lot
about sort of the basic chemistry of the
brain how neurons fire how chemical
signals are sent and so on and we know a
furbit about big bits of the brain their
function in the overall economy what
we're almost clueless on is how those
big functions are realized at the
cellular level and I'd want to know a
lot more about that before I'm convinced
that we can reduce everything that's
going on to underlying chemistry and
physics and therefore there's no free
will so I think it's an open question
and I would say it seems like we have
free will and so in the absence of any
empirical argument one way or the other
I think we can tentatively believe in
free will and you're right that's an
important part of addressing the problem
of evil but well actually you're
completely right that the you know
cancer is an evil it's maybe a little
bit of a misnomer because the way the
word is used in this context it it it is
often used to mean just a bad thing it
should really be the problem of evil and
suffering but still so I think Free Will
can go a long way with human evil
perhaps but really it's naturally
natural suffering that gets me and one
what I focus on in the book actually and
so I engage a lot with the work of the
Christian philosopher Richard swinburn
who um is reviewing it for the Times
litery supplement actually and giving
his responses and then we're going to
have a little debate on it on the The
Unbelievable podcast he tries to argue
that there are certain good things in a
universe with natural suffering cancer
earthquakes hurricane that we wouldn't
have in a in a universe without what we
call Natural evil I I agree with you
that's a bad word for it
like he thinks that we wouldn't have
significant moral choices like the
decision whether to show courage whether
to show compassion whether to choose to
hurt or to harm we'd just be in some
kind of Disneyland with no serious moral
choices we'd be like the idol Rich so my
response to this is even if he's right
about that I don't think a creator has
the right to kill and maim in order to
bring about these Goods by creating
hurricanes and earthquakes and so on you
know just as I mean there's a classic
example to very crude forms of
utilitarian moral philosophy you know
imagine we have a doctor who could kill
one healthy patient to save five you
know it gives the lungs to one the heart
to another well that doctor would
increase
well-being by um you know F saving five
lives at the cost of one and let's
pretend you know no one's ever going to
find out about it or something but most
of us think still the doctor does not
have the right to take that person's
life similarly I think I think a Creator
even if they could bring about great
Goods by creating hurricanes and
earthquakes I don't think it would be
acceptably Mor acceptable morally for a
Creator to infringe our rights to to
life and health and security by creating
natural disasters so yeah so it's an
interesting take on that I think well I
just want to exercise uh the beneficence
of my audience and beseech their free
will uh so last time you were on Phil
that we got tens of thousands of views
but very troublingly for me at least
only about 50% I don't know if you can
see this only about 50% of the viewers
of this wonderful life-changing podcast
with you uh and me last time Chang my
life for the better um are subscribed to
the channel and so I'm asking everybody
out there if you're if you're listening
if you're enjoying this please do
consider subscribing and leaving a
comment because that really helps me get
these wonderful guests like Phil and and
his contemporaries and colleagues like
David chmer and Nick Bostrom and Brian
Green is is coming up on the podcast as
well as David uh Z Albert uh philosopher
of physics at Columbia is coming on so
we want to get great episodes and and
this will help help me help you out
there so please do consider subscribing
so Phil we we talked about you know kind
of this this notion of of free will in a
universe of you know with a God or not
and I should say I also don't believe in
you know many of the kind of childish
conceptions of God of the white beard
you know Yuri gargeran when he orbited
the Earth for the first time in
1961 uh he came back and he said they
asked him what did you see and he said
well I didn't see a guy in a white beard
I'm like well nobody thought you'd see a
guy in a white beard unless you're an
idiot but you know this kind of simpl
yeah I also don't believe in some of the
gods that Lawrence Krauss doesn't
believe in but I ask you you know
because one of the extrapolations of
what you just said this doctor that can
save five um so let's say we've had on
many many um people including your
countrymen and and uh uh a fellow
brilliant scientist uh and thinker um
Tim Palmer and we talked about the
existential nature of of global warming
and human induced climate change and uh
we'll get around to fine-tuning and
climate change denialism in just a bit
but there's a a strong contingent that
you mention in in the opening chapter of
the book was called anti-natalism and
anti-natalism is the movement to uh
reduce the population of of Earth in
order to prevent primarily to prevent
induced uh climate change effects
leading to the uninhabitability of the
planet and many people have proposed
this I always say well you know the
natural conclusion of that is if if it's
good not to have kids that it's better
to kill everybody else including the
anti-natalist so I'm always like you
first how do you react to a world where
that in Judaism and Christianity and
Islam I assume is is forbidden you know
suicide you know and so for but even the
notion of decreasing human population
you know humans are inherently infinite
in value in Judaism as as being but
Salam Elohim in in this in the image of
God in the in a spark of of God so tell
me isn't there a danger of the slippery
slope that you get on the anti-natalism
route and then it leads to well we
shouldn't be here at all and in fact
many people have said that we should not
be here at all it's really interesting
just just going back to I come to that
in a second but just going back to what
you're saying about uh the old man in
the sky and so on I mean maybe maybe in
a sense we're not so far apart because
well one thing one thing I'm trying to
do in this book is you know consider
things that aren't the familiar options
and just get people to think about them
and you're not going to agree with all
it but one thing I consider is religious
fictionalism the possibility of engaging
a tradition a religious practice even
without necessarily having the beliefs
and you know religion isn't just about
the belief bits you know it's about
rights of Passage that bring Community
together you know and mark the seasons
and the big moments of Life birth
marriage death Coming of Age tradition
spiritual practice and so I was raised
Catholic um but the Catholicism I
suppose in my parents was more about
community and rather than dogma and
although I I didn't get confirmed uh
like you didn't get your bids for when
you were a child um you still confirm
though I did get confirmed in the
Catholic church that's
really Phil I was
I was I was a Terri I was a terrible
alter boy I was always ringing the bell
at the wrong time I still found deep
meaning in in in the the symbolism of
Christianity the the centralite
inversion of worldly values that you
know we're identifying God not with the
king in his castle but with the naked
executed peasant you know the guy who
hung out with Sinners and outcasts and
loved his enemies and so on so I still
find great meaning in that and I'm you
know I'm sure Sim similar in in the
Hebrew Bible lots of these powerful
symbolic meanings but anyway coming
directly to your question well that
sounds almost like a a a more moderate
thought form of anti-natalism you were
discussing there because so what I what
I discuss in the book is even more
radical the view of um the anti-natalist
philosopher who
thinks life is not entirely meaningless
but is so meaningless that actually
it's immoral to have Offspring because
you're bringing uh people into this
incredibly meaningless universe and the
the the moral thing to do is to let the
human race pass out of existence so he's
not I don't think he's concerned with
climate change he's not just reducing
the population to save the planet he
thinks this is the ethical thing this
has become a a small religion in its own
right actually the um there's an guy in
India who tried to to his parents for
bringing him to existence without his
consent and uh so yeah I I mean well
what I I considered like this one
extreme so you get the anti-natalist
atheist view the view of William Lane
Craig that if there's no purpose to the
universe we might as well just rape and
murder each other he actually says you
know we do what the hell we want if
there's no it's all pointless and then
at the Other Extreme again it's all
about the dichotomies for me the Other
Extreme you got the familiar secular
atheist position that you know probably
there's no point to the universe but
even if there is it's irrelevant you
know I make my own meaning I make my own
purpose so the middle ground option I
kind of more inclin towards is yes you
can have a perfectly
meaningful happy life independently of
whether there's a purpose to the
universe but if if there's there is some
kind of as i' argue in the book I try to
take Ser I think there's reason to take
seriously there is some some kind of
purpose or goal directedness at the
fundamental level there's may be the P
the possibility of having a more
meaningful life you know we we want our
we want our lives to make a difference
if you could in some small way
contribute to the purposes of the whole
of reality that's huge that's about as
big a difference as you can imagine
making so so this Cosmic propos vist
position as we might call it is one way
of approaching the meaning of life
conceiving of the good you do in in a in
a broader ethical project that
encompasses the whole of reality and
again you know I'm never I'm into like
dogmatically laying down the law this is
the one true way of living a life but
it's at least interesting to consider to
and I I'd like people to sort of
entertain these alternatives to both
traditional religion and the familiar
secular atheist option so uh there's so
much to talk about we could do many many
hours I want to make sure to get in some
questions from my audience ask me on
Twitter where you can follow uh Phil as
well at Philip goof with one L and
Philip uh so there's a question that
really kind of resonated With Me based
on some of the conversations I heard you
with my friend Robert cun on closer to
truth recently and talking about fine
tuning and uh there's a tweet I guess it
was last week from from you that said
there are many scientific papers
presenting the case for fine tuning this
is no different to climate change denial
that's a shocking Revelation I mean I
mean to hear you say that really shocked
me and it's a screenshot so I don't know
if you really said that so tell me uh is
there uh can you explain what did you
mean by the statement that it's no
different than climate change denial
well right so it's important to realize
what we mean by fine tuning or what I
mean which I think is fairly standard is
just that for life to be possible
certain numbers in physics had to fall
in a certain narrow range that's the
empirical datum that I'm focusing on now
there there are other things that are
more you know are rightly debated for
example coming back to Sabine
hossenfelder she doubts that we can get
a probability claim out of that so it's
a it's a further step to say fine tuning
is improbable oh how improbable that are
that are univers allow for life that's a
further step now I think you can make
that step and I get heavily into the you
know probability Theory but that is
rightly debated and that's a that's a
perfectly legitimate debate um but the
but the but if you just get a lot of
people on Twitter just flatly denying
any scientifically cred credibility and
you know and it just seems to be that
that that there's a fairly solid
empirical case for example the
cosmological constant um you know that
that that that if it had been
significantly bigger no two particles
would have would have ever met
everything would have been pushed apart
so quickly so the cosmological constant
is measures the force that pushes apart
the universe whereas if it had been less
than zero so it's my understanding is
it's very very very close to zero very
small but uh not zero if it had been
negative if it had passed surpassed zero
and become negative well then it would
it would have it wouldn't have
counteracted gravity and so the universe
would have collapsed back on itself a
split second after the big bang so so
look there's all sorts of things you can
say here you could say like Roger
Penrose does well I think I think I
think it's going to change I think the
physics will change and and the
fine-tuning will
disappear I mean that's an option but to
my mind that's it's almost like
artificially ramping up the standards of
evidence in a way we wouldn't do in
other places like oh we can't draw
conclusions from fine tuning until we've
completed physics you know I mean it
could be we'll complete physics and the
fine tuning will go away or it could be
there's more fine tuning anyway that's
I've I've digressed there slightly but
but so there's lots of things to debate
here people who say on Twitter I don't
find scientists saying this there was
this one guy Stanger who used to say
this but generally I don't find
physicist saying this but people on
social media say no it's all nonsense
there's no scientific case for this
basic empirical datum that for life to
be possible for any kind of structural
complexity possible these numbers the
the values of the constant had to fall
in a certain quite narrow range I think
that's sort of just equalent to just
denying the empirical data for
ideological reasons I think right it's
it's to to think about you know fine
tuning I guess the some of the uh
comments and questions that I've had
have to do with the definition of
fine-tuning so depending on how you look
at fine-tuning when you go back in in
time the certain problems get you know
inextricably uh difficult and and and
there's there completely intractable I
mean if you change the density of the
universe by one atom or one proton at uh
at the equivalent of you know one atosc
after the big bang um and you add one
proton the universe collapses but if you
add one proton today nothing happens
right so there's time dependent you know
fine-tuning and then there's you know
material dependent fine tuning in other
words we don't know what dark energy is
we don't know what the inflaton is or if
it exists that's actually what pays my
my rent around here because I'm
searching for the aftershocks of
inflation or it's Alternatives and I
guess the the you know kind of competing
theme that I keep hearing from my
brilliant audience is you know how would
you know that your supposition is is
wrong um you know in other words
Steelman kind of the the opposition to
your thesis about fine-tuning and I
wonder if you could do that
simultaneously with this inverse
gambler's fallacy Paradox so first
Define what the gambler's Paradox is uh
fallacy is then Define the inverse of
that that you use so skillfully uh in a
lot of your um a lot of your thinking
and writing and then how how would you
know that that the supposition about
fine tuning might be wrong your
supposition about fine tuning would be
wrong so the inverse Gambler stuff
relates to is an important objection to
the Multiverse I mean I I for a long
time I thought the Multiverse was the
the most plausible account here I've
always thought fine tuning needed
explaining but I thought you know I
don't I don't want to believe in Cosmic
purpose it feels as peculiar to me as as
it does to anyone else um and I so I
used to think oh it's probably the
Multiverse but I was just persuaded over
a long period of time that there's that
there's some dodgy reasoning going on in
the inference from fine-tuning to a
Multiverse and and basically then that
you know that there's some Dody reason
going on in huge proportion of
theoretical physics potentially um and
you know what I'm quite excited about
this book actually this is not original
to me it's this has been in the the
academic literature on probability for
decades but in a classic case of
academics talking to themselves nobody
knows about it outside of academic
philosophy of probability You know
despite huge interest in fine-tuning
among you know religious people arguing
for God or certain scientists arguing
for the Multiverse anyway right so so we
you people might be familiar with the
gamblers fallacy that you've had bad run
of luck all night and you think well I'm
bound to have a good luck this time I'm
bound to roll a double six this time
because I've rolled badly all night
everyone knows that's a fallacy cuz the
odds of getting a double six one in 36
the same every time it's irrelevant
whether you've just started or you've
been playing all night the inverse
gamblers
fallacy kind of does that in Reverse so
well the example I like to give suppose
Brian I I I come and visit you and we go
to a you take me to a wonderful casino
and we walk in and we see we're in this
we walk into this small room with just
one person playing roulette and they're
just having an incredible run of luck
they're just winning and winning and
winning and winning and I and I say wow
the casino must be busy tonight and you
say what are you talking about we just
seen this one guy how what's that got to
do with other rooms in the casino and I
say well if the if the tens of thousands
of people playing Roulette in the casino
then it's not so surprising that
someone someone in the casino is going
to have an incredible run of look at R
run of look at L roulette and that's
just what we've observed someone having
an incredible run of Lu at roulette now
everyone agrees that's a fallacy that's
the inverse gamblers fallacy our
observational evidence is this
particular individual has played well
people in other rooms in the casino it's
irrelevant that's a fallacy everyone
agrees but it looks IND discernible from
the reasoning of the Multiverse theorist
you know they observe oh my God the
numbers in physics are just right for
Life there must be lots of other
universes with terrible numbers but that
is just as our observational evidence
concern this one Universe we've observed
and just as other rooms in the casino
are relevant to the success of this one
person in front of us so are the
universes are irrelevant to explaining
the fine tuning we see that's the basic
idea but I'm sure there's lots to debate
here the Multiverse of course you know
many of the I I recently sat down just
for an informal conversation with David
Albert and Columbia and we talked about
you know the philosophy of cosmology and
and how the Multiverse is kind of this
this you know almost you know too good
to be true solution to so many different
uh different problems in cosmology and
yet it's it's it's not necessarily
mandated by any one physical Theory I
mean it's a consequence of string theory
of M Theory and some cases but you know
let's say we fast forward and we get a
letter from God I don't want to say God
but you know we get a letter that says
you know inflation uh is undetectable
and it may have happened or it may not
have happened if it happened it may have
happened at an energy scale too
insufficient to create the
reverberations in SpaceTime that my
colleagues and I are trying to detect
with the Simon Observatory uh the
so-call B mode polarization of the CMB
um but in that case you know where do we
go what what conclusions in the in in a
universe that's potentially in a
Multiverse but can never be can never be
falsified to uh to not be in a
Multiverse and there are many competing
theories that don't predict
gravitational waves at all those can be
falsified um sir Roger Penrose you know
nearby you is is proponent of one of
them so how do you react to to that it
that it may never be provable or
falsifiable that the Multiverse is or
INF let's just say inflation took place
let alone the Multiverse well yeah I
mean this is kind of outside of my pre
grade to be honest assessing the I mean
but one thing I do do in the book which
is extraordinarily again something
that's never been done before connecting
up this specific object ction to the
Multiverse the inverse gamblers fallacy
to the scientific discussions of the
Multiverse it's I mean I don't know
academics just get I'm not saying this
is my Brilliance it's just how academics
just get focused in such a narrow thing
that they don't it's unbelievable but
anyway I try to link it up and I I try
to argue that yeah look I'm not a
physicist I can't assess the the
inflationary case for the Multiverse or
not but what I try to argue in the book
and maybe it' take too long to go into
this people can look it up but I tried
to say that even if even if you go for
the inflationary Multiverse the only way
to avoid the inverse gamblers fallacy is
to think all of the all or most of the
universes are fine-tuned so the problem
doesn't go away and anyway that's what I
try to show and um and of course there's
issues about anthropic selection effect
and so on I mean I go into this in great
detail but I mean just briefly with the
with the analogy we gave you could add a
little artificial selection effect right
imagine there's as we walk into the
casino there's a hidden sniper at the
back who's going to blow our brains out
if if the person in playing roulette
doesn't have an incredible run of luck
well then there's a selection effect we
we the only thing we could have observed
is someone having an incredible run of
luck but it's still a fallacy likewise
whilst it's true that we couldn't have
observed a non- fine-tuned universe I
don't think that makes a difference to
the fallacy but anyway it you know so
the book goes into more more more depth
or less depth depending on how you want
to take it and then I'm going to take
one uh question from YouTube or Dr Brian
keing also if you're listening on the
podcast app uh be sure to tune in to the
subscribe to the channel as well uh
because there are many different uh fun
things that you get over there that you
don't necessarily get on audio only um
this is from Maliki Marvin he asked
we're the ones who assigned purposes to
things so I guess the real question is
do we have a use for it how do how do
you react to that we as humans I assume
are what is describing purpose so it
shouldn't the question be do we have do
we have uh the right or use or is it
evolutionary or in any way contingent
that we have a purpose or we can ascribe
purpose I know that's the way we tend to
think of things that purposes just come
from human beings but I suppose I'd want
to ask Malachi what's your argument for
that the seem coherent Poss
possibilities or I try to lay out in
great detail in the book coherent
possibilities where there is purpose in
the universe independently of human
beings um I consider for example the
cosmos psychist view that the universe
is itself a conscious mind with its own
goals or if you if pans psychism is too
wacky for you I discuss Thomas Nagel's
view in his book mind and Cosmos that
there are teleological laws laws of
nature with purposes built into them and
some philosophers have really spelt out
a very rigorous account of this so it
seems to be coherent and I think
fine-tuning and certain facts that we
haven't gone into about the evolution of
Consciousness I would argue give us
strong reason to take it seriously and I
I I sort of think we're in a little bit
of Deni a bit in denial about this at
the moment it's maybe like in the 16th
century when we first started getting
evidence that we're not in the center of
the universe and people struggled to
accept that because it didn't fit with
the picture of reality they'd got used
to and nowadays we scoff at those people
we stupid religious people why couldn't
they just follow the evidence but every
generation absorbs a world view they
can't see beyond I think that's what's
going on with fine tuning now I think
future historians will look back and
think why did they just ignore this fine
tun why didn't they see it's
obviously evidence for Cosmic purpose
and you know the the one thing about the
time we're living in is we've got this
little thing called Baye theorem this
little bit of mathematics which tells us
how evidential support Works to my mind
a pretty straightforward application of
bay theorem um to fine-tuning spits out
evidence for Cosmic purpose I just think
we're in denial about it because for
cultural reasons you know we're very
well trained in the west I think to be
alert to religious biases maybe from a
religious upbringing and that's good and
that's good what is not talked about
very often is secular biases maybe
there's in a secular World viiew certain
you know I feel silly talking about
these things we have a word for for
religious you know intolerance it's a
religious fundamentalism and I think
that's true and I think there is a
evolutionary or maybe culturally you
know High utility function for being
very skeptical about religion because it
it's the best it may be a good form of
morality and and Ethos but it's a
horrible form of government right and so
we interact with the government where
animous politicus as your friend
Aristotle would say right we're
Political Animals but Phil so we should
be very very suspicious of the
theocracies right those are really bad
but we should also have a word for the
equivalent you know atheist mil militant
atheist should be atheist fundamentalism
yeah we'll have to talk again about this
because this is so fascina I would love
to come on your podcast um I've had you
on twice now done a trailer episode I am
throwing down the gauntlet I would love
to come on your podcast let's do it for
hours maybe debate with love and comedy
and a little comedy but today we're
talking uh got a wrap up uh with my
friend and truly Phil you're such a men
I I love talking to you I love your
podcast M chat with um how do you say
your co-host uh name I always have
trouble with Keith Keith Frankish it's
Keith Frankish where podcast I always
say with the lowest production values
and the best best philosophy we're too
busy with kids and work to edit videos
have we just hit broadcast uh and do
some silly stuff and talk about philos
we're GNA put CS to your debate with
Sean Carol who I've often debated and
I'd love to i' love to um as I say a
Shameless plug for myself absolutely
absolutely just say very briefly because
I didn't quite explain I talked about
how physicalism can't explain stuff but
psychism can't we didn't really get into
that but if the debate with Sean Carol
starts off with a statement of
explaining all that so if people want to
hear more about that you can check out
which is on my mind chat Channel well I
I love that episode and Phil I love this
book beautifully written um and uh of
course academically there's chock full
of citations and some of our friends and
past guests like Gant Lewis and many
others Phil thank you so much I'm sorry
it was short we'll do a part two or I'll
do a part one on your show have a
wonderful day and night really for you
thanks for staying up so late and being
so such a such a wonderful guest as
usual oh thanks so much Brian it's been
wonderful thanks for having me on again
all right take care